Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin der Stabende Arsene auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich Frau Doktor.
So als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann direkt Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Christina Schmolinski.
Christina Schmolinski.
Frau Schmolinski, können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestätigen?
Schmolinski.
M-A oder M-O?
M-O.
Frau Schmolinski, wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 75, Frau Doktor.
75, ok. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ja, 1. April 1950.
Ok. Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege ungefähr 72 Kilogramm und ich bin 1 Meter 65 groß.
Ok. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Herr Hans Müller.
Hans Müller. Ok. Vielen Dank für diese Informationen, Frau Schmolinski. Und was für Sie heute sonst? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, Frau Doktor, normalerweise treibe ich sehr oft Sport. Ich laufe gerne und ich habe alle Sportorte gemacht, aber seit 6 Monaten kann ich nicht Sport treiben.
6 Monate?
Ja, weil ich Knie Schmerzen habe.
Knie Schmerzen.
Ja.
Hatten Sie eine neue Beschwerden für Rühe?
Ja, manchmal hatte ich, aber seit 6 Monaten habe ich echt Knie Schmerzen. Ich kann nicht besonders runtersteigen.
Wenn ich runtersteige, habe ich sehr schlechte Knie Schmerzen und ich kann nicht laufen. Zuerst waren die Schmerzen nicht schlecht, aber im Verlauf der Zeit sehr schlimm geworden.
Jede Nacht war ich auf wegen Schmerzen.
Ok. Haben Sie Schlafprobleme auch?
Ja, wegen Schmerzen. Ich war auf wegen Knie Schmerzen.
Ok. Ich möchte fragen, haben Sie diese Schmerzen bei Belastung oder in Ruhe auch?
Jetzt, seit einem Monat, habe ich auch in Ruhe. Aber vor 6 Monaten hatte ich nur bei Belastung Schmerzen, aber jetzt sind alles schiefgelaufen.
Ok, ich verstehe.
Es ist sehr schwer Sport zu treiben. Das ist sehr schlecht geworden.
Ich werde Ihnen helfen, Frau Schmucki, bitte machen Sie keine Sorgen. Sie haben Knie Schmerzen. Und jetzt haben Sie Knie Schmerzen?
Ja, ich habe jetzt auch Knie Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei ein der lahten 10 sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, jetzt sehe ich, deswegen habe ich vielleicht 6 Schmerzen. Aber bei Belastung habe ich 8 oder 9 Schmerzen. Besonders bei runtersteigen, das ist sehr schlecht.
Ok. Strange Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Ich spüre Besonders in der Knie, aber manchmal war es schlecht. Manchmal war es schlecht. Aber vorne Schmerzen.
Vorne, ok.
Haben Sie etwas Gefühl, dass es nicht gut ist?
Nein, ich fühle mich nicht taub als Gefühl. Oder Kribbel habe ich nicht.
Ok. Haben Sie oder ist Ihnen eine kraftlos, wenig Kraft am Bein oder am Finger?
Kraftlos habe ich nicht, aber meine Bewegung ist eingeschränkt. Ich kann nicht ablaufen, deswegen ist es für mich schlimm.
Ok. Ist Ihnen eine Hautveränderung zum Beispiel, kalte Haut oder eine blaue Farbing am Bein oder am Knie aufgefallen?
Nein, ich habe kein kalter Gefühl. Manchmal fühle ich mich ein wenig überwärmt. Manchmal, nicht oft.
Haben Sie für diese Beschwerden früher beim Arzt aufgesucht?
Ja, ja. Ich habe meinen Arzt besucht und er hat mir Ibuprofen, Paracetamol und eine Salbe geschrieben.
Aber jetzt hilft mir nichts. Vor sechs Monaten die Salbe und die Medikamente haben mir geholfen. Aber jetzt hilft mir leider nichts.
Ok.
Frau Doktor, in der Nacht habe ich Schmerzen. Das ist sehr schlimm.
Ok. Haben Sie andere Begleitsymptome? Haben Sie Fieber oder Stahlfruss?
Ich habe nicht Fieber oder Stahlfruss, aber manchmal fühle ich Überwärmung in den Knie.
Ok. Ja, ich verstehe.
Besonders wenn es regnet, fühle ich Schmerzen mehr als sonst.
Ok. Wenn es regnet, mehr Schmerzen.
Ja, ja. Ich fühle mehr als sonst.
Ok. Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein, habe ich keine Übelkeit.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht. Aber meine beiden Knie sind ein bisschen dick geworden.
Seit wann?
Seit drei Monaten vielleicht.
Drei Monate? Ok.
Wie Flüssigkeit in der Knie gesammelt. Ich weiß nicht.
Ok. Ja, ich verstehe. Danke schön für diese Information.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ungewöhnlich Ab- oder Zugenommen?
Ja, ich kann nicht gut bewegen. Deswegen habe ich drei Kilo Zugenommen in den letzten sechs Monaten.
Ich kann nicht Sport treiben. Normalerweise laufe ich gerne und jogue.
Aber ich kann nicht diese Sportorte machen. Deswegen habe ich Zugenommen.
Ok. Hatten Sie einen Unfall oder Verletzung in den sechs Monaten?
Nein, ich habe vor 30 Jahren gefallen. Aber ich bin gefallen.
Ok. Ja. Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Basalasen oder Zugenken?
Nein, nein. Es ist normal.
Ok. Wie ist es?
Manchmal spüre ich oder leide ich an Verstopfung. Manchmal. Nicht immer, manchmal.
Haben Sie jetzt Verstopfung?
Ja, ja. Ich habe jetzt Verstopfung.
Wann war Ihre letzte Stunde?
Vor zwei Tagen.
Ich gehe zum Klo dreimal pro Woche.
Ok.
Ja, ich kann nicht gut bewegen. Deswegen bewegt mein Darm auch nicht.
Ja, Sie haben recht. Ok.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, ich esse gerne.
Ok. Sie esse gerne und essen Sie auch Fleisch?
Ja, ja. Ich esse gerne.
Ok. Frau Christina, sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, mein Blutfettwerte sind erhöht.
Seit wann?
Seit vielleicht zehn Jahren.
Zehn Jahre. Ok.
Und dagegen nehme ich Simmastatin, 20 Milligramm, abends.
Ok.
Und mein Teil des Dickdarms ist vor acht Jahren entfernt.
Ok. Vor acht Jahren.
Vor acht Jahren entfernt. Und meine Mandeln wurden mit acht Lebensjahren auch entfernt, als ich Kind war.
Acht.
Mit acht Jahren, ja.
Warum hatten Sie eine Darmoperation?
Ich verstehe nicht.
Ja, ich hatte einmal Blut beim Stuhl und wurde eine Kolonoskopie durchgeführt.
Und mein Arzt hat mir gesagt, dass ich Divertikulitis hatte.
Ok.
Deswegen hat mein Schirurg meinen Dickdarm entfernt.
Ok. Ich verstehe.
Gute Bezögerung. War die Operation komplikationlos?
Ja, hatte ich keine Probleme mehr.
Sie haben hochfettwerte und noch etwas?
Nein, ich habe keine andere Beschwerden.
Manchmal spüre ich Aufschluss oder Bauchschmerzen.
Deswegen nehme ich manchmal eine Pantoproson.
Wenn ich Fett reiche, dann nehme ich eine Pantoproson.
Ok. Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Operation.
Eine Operation, die ich jetzt in der Klinik habe.
Ok. Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Das ist bis auf eine Mandelentfernung oder Diktarmentfernung entfernt?
Zweimal wurde ich Operation gemacht.
Nur zweimal.
Ok. Sind Sie Racherin, Frau Szomolinski?
Ja, mit dem Rachen habe ich vor zehn Jahren aufgehört.
Bevor habe ich 20 Jahre lang ein Schachtel Zigaretten geraucht.
Ok. Trinken Sie auch Alkohol?
Ab und zu trinke ich Bier. Einmal oder zweimal pro Woche.
Ok. Ein Flaschbier oder?
Ja, ein Flaschen Bier.
Ok. Ein oder zweimal pro Woche.
Ja.
Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, Frau Doktor. Niemals.
Ok. Früher haben Sie viele Sport gemacht. Laufen oder andere.
Wie oft hätten Sie diese Sport machen?
Ja, mindestens dreimal pro Woche habe ich gelaufen, geschwommen und so weiter. Fahrrad gefahren bin ich.
Ok. Haben Sie Hüften oder Atemnot?
Jetzt? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ja, jetzt. Oder Brutschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstoffe, Herzklopfen?
Nein, ich spüre keine Herzstoffe.
Frau Smolenski, sind Sie in Wechsel?
Ich bin 75, Frau Doktor. Vor 30 Jahren vielleicht. 25 Jahre.
25 Jahre, ok.
Ja, ja.
Und gehen Sie regelmäßig zu Ihrem Frauenarzt?
Ja, gehe ich regelmäßig. Einmal pro Jahr besuche ich meine Frauenärztin.
Ok. Alle sind in Ordnung?
Ja, normalerweise alle sind in Ordnung.
Frau Smolenski, gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, mein Vater und meine Mutter sind gestorben.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid. Warum? Wie sind Sie?
Mein Vater ist plötzlich mit Brutschschmerzen gestorben.
Ok.
Vielleicht mit Herzproblemen, ich weiß nicht. Aber meine Mutter ist an Lungenkrebs vor 30 Jahren gestorben.
Und meine Schwester ist an Eierstockkrebs gestorben.
Und mein Bruder ist leider an Dichternkrebs.
Ok. Es tut mir sehr leid. Und was machen Sie? Sie sind Rentnerin und früher... Was haben Sie?
Ich war Lehrerin, Frau Doktor. Ich habe 35 Jahre gearbeitet als Lehrerin.
Sehr schön. Und sind Sie verheiratet? Oder leben Sie alleine?
Ja, ich bin jetzt alleine. Mein Mann ist an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid zu hören. Ok. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder. Gott sei Dank sind sie gerünt. Alle sind gestorben.
Ok. Sind Sie gegen Allergien?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie.
Ok. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Haus?
Nein.
Frau Schumolowski, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen. Und keine Zeit auch.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, ich habe keine weitere Frage, Frau Doktor. Was planen Sie?
Frau Schumolowski, ich werde Sie jetzt in der Körperwahl untersuchen, dann Blut abnehmen und einige weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und ich werde Sie mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen etwas Genres sagen.
Bitte warten Sie mich in der Untersuchung und ich werde gleich nach Ihnen kommen.
Ok Frau Doktor, vielen Dank.
Danke schön. Bitte schön.
Ok. Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt. Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie Kussleid für mich?
Ja, bitte schön.
Ich habe eine klinische Schmerzenmenschung. Der Patient berichtete, dass die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten sind.
Besonders bei Bewegung.
Und sich mit der Zeit verschlechtert haben.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei Bewegung bis 8 bis 9 von 10.
Und in Ruhe 6 bei 6 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Der Patient beschreibt die Schmerzen als eine Stehende Schmerzen.
Und die Schmerzen strahlen in der Wade und den Oberschenkel aus.
Die Fragen nach Parasite, Paralysie und Parasie wurden verneilt.
Der Patient hat diese Schmerzen besonders in der Nacht.
Und deshalb hat sie Insomni.
Und sie gab an, dass die Schmerzen beim Regnen verschleimert sind.
Die Patienten klagten über seit 3 Monaten.
Die Patienten klagten seit 2 Monaten.
Und er gieß im Knie gelenkt.
Welche Seite hat diese Patienten?
Beide Kniegelenke hat der Patient.
Also bilaterale.
Bilaterale Ödämme und er gieß an den Beinen.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Insomni.
Der Patient hat eine Gewichtssunahme von 3 kg innerhalb von 6 Monaten.
Der Patient hat manchmal Verstoffung.
Welchen Fachbegriff?
Obstubation.
Die Patienten berichtet über Bewegungen an Schrankungen.
Beide Beine aufgrund dieser Schmerzen.
Besonders Rundeschreie.
Die Anforderungen leiden sie an Cholestronomie seit 10 Jahren.
Sie nimmt gegen Simvastatin 40 mg abends.
Und die Patienten nehmen bei Bedarf aufgrund Magenprobleme Cholestronomie.
Magenprobleme Pantaprazole.
Die Patienten haben vor 10 Jahren mit dem Rachen aufgehört.
Sie hat seit 20 Jahren 20 Zigaretten pro Tag gerauft.
Sie trinkt ein Flasche Bier.
Ein Flasche Bier 1-2 pro Woche.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie war sportlich bis 6 Monate.
Aber sie hat keine Sportaufgrund dieser Schmerzen gemacht.
In der Familienanamnese wurde angegeben, dass ihr Vater an einer Herzkrankheit verstorben.
Und ihr Mutter an einem Bronchialkarsino verstorben.
Sie hat zwei Geschwister.
Ihr Schwester hat einen Ova-Karsino.
Und ihr Bruder hat einen Kolonkarsino.
Sie ist Rentnerin.
Frühe hat sie als Lehrerin gearbeitet.
Sie ist verwidmet.
Sie hat Zwei-Gesunde.
Sie hat keine Vekantenallergie.
Sie ist verständigt geübt.
Die Anamnese ist unaufhörig.
Die Anamnistischen haben dort am Ehesten eine Gonatrose.
Als die Pheranzenstheorose in Betracht kam,
war sie entstanden.
Sie hatte eine Fraktur.
Sie hatte eine Astiphanzerdiagnose.
Sie hatte Arthritis.
Sie hatte eine peripherale Arterie.
Sie hatte eine Falschuluskrankheit in Betracht.
Sie hatte eine Zureichung.
Sie sollte folgende Ausnahmen durchgeführt werden.
Sie sollte die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Sie sollte durch Blut, Motorik und Sensibilität untersuchen.
Sie sollte die Pulse kontrollieren.
Sie sollte die Pulse inspezieren.
Sie sollte die Hautveränderung, die Kälte, die Überwärmung, die Haut verändern.
Warum?
Meine Pheranzenstheorose ist die Pheranzenstheorie, die ich durch die Pheranzenstheorie auslesen kann.
Ich würde alle Reflexe kontrollieren.
Dann werde ich eine Röntgenaufnahme vorveranlassen.
Röntgenaufnahme, ich meine eine Kniegelenk- und Unterchenkel- und Kniegelenk-Röntgenaufnahme vorveranlassen.
Ich würde auch eine CT oder eine MRT, eine besondere MRT, vorveranlassen.
Warum?
Die MRT für die weitere Pheranzenstheorie, die ich durch die Pheranzenstheorie auslesen kann.
Um die möglichen weichen Verteidigungen auszuschließen.
Als differenzierter Diagnose kann ich sagen, dass es eine Methastasien oder Tumor ist.
Warum denken Sie so?
Meine Pheranzenstheorie ist Osteoporose, Arthritis und PAVK.
Um meine Pheranzenstheorie auszuschließen, werde ich eine MRT und eine CT vorveranlassen.
Wir haben schon körperliche Untersuchungen gemacht, auch die Apparatistik-mimosen Methoden.
Bei der Laboruntersuchung würde ich ein großes Blutbild, ein Zündungparameter BSG-CRP und einige Rheumatoide-Faktoren bestimmen lassen.
Wenn ich die Pheranzenstheorie vorgelegt habe, würde ich die Pheranzenstheorie auslesen.
Sollte sich die Pheranzenstheorie bestätigen, schlage ich die folgende Therapie vor.
Ich möchte die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde die Patienten stationär aufnehmen, um die weiteren Untersuchungen zu optimieren.
Ich würde die Patienten an der Analyse verbreiten.
Ich empfehle den Patienten Gewichtsreduktion und Physiotherapie.
Falls die Patienten mit Medikamentöse-Therapie nicht gut behandelt werden, schlage ich eine operative Therapie vor.
Eine operative Therapie kann mit Patienten eine totale Knieprothese einsetzen.
Ich würde die Patienten an der Analyse verbreiten.
Und natürlich die Physiotherapie.
Physiologie, Rehabilitation oder?
Nach der Untersuchung empfehle ich den Patienten nicht alleine bleiben.
Deshalb kann die Patiententforschung über ein Pflegeheim oder Pflegeheim.
Und ich empfehle den Patienten auch eine Krankengymnastik.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Arthroskopie durchführen würden.
Könnten Sie bitte Arthroskopie aufklären?
Arthroskopie ist eine Gelenkspiegelung, um die betroffenen Gelenken zu beurteilen.
Mit Hilfe der Arthroskopie können wir auch soviel diagnostisch.
Ich glaube, dass die Patienten eine Arthroskopie durchführen.
Sie können auch in 6 Stunden nüchtern sein.
Diese Untersuchung ist schmerzhaft.
Ich glaube, dass die Patienten eine Arthroskopie durchführen.
Das ist eine Schmerzhaft-Untersuchung.
Deshalb machen wir diese Untersuchung unter Spinal Anesthesie oder Vollnarkose.
Wir benutzen eine flexible Schlaufe in den Gelenk.
Wir zeigen alle inneren Strukturen und die Pathologie.
Dann können wir eine Gewebeprobe entnehmen.
Dann können wir kleine operative Eingriffe durchführen.
Nach der Untersuchung sollten die Patienten nicht allein bleiben.
Vor der Untersuchung sollten die Patienten eine begleitete Person mitbringen.
Die Patienten müssen nicht allein fahren oder zu Hause gehen.
Deshalb braucht man eine begleitete Person.
Das war es für heute.
Ich habe eine Frage zu Christina Schmolonsky.
Sie ist eine 75-jährige Patientin.
Sie wurde am 1. April 1950.
Sie ist 1,65 Meter groß und 72 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie stellte sich bei uns vor aufgrund seines sechs Monats bewegungsabhängiger, stechender Kniegelenkschmerzen.
Sie hat sich mit Ausstrahlung in die Koksa ausgesucht.
Sie berichtet, die Schmerzen seien sich beim runtersteigen verschlechtert.
Sie wurde in Ruhe mit 6 von 10.
Sie wurde mit 8 bis 9 von 10 bewertet.
Sie hat die Patientin gegen diese Schmerzen eine Medikamente angenommen?
Sie war bei einem Hausarzt.
Der Hausarzt hat ihm Paracetamol und Salbe verschrieben.
Die Therapie hat aber seit sechs Monaten nicht geholfen.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegt eine Überwärmung vor.
Die Frage nach Hautverfärbung, Parasite, Parastese, Unfall wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Gewichtsunahme.
Sie ist 3 Kilogramm innerhalb von drei Monaten.
Sie hat Obstepation.
Sie ist dreimal in einer Woche ins Omni, wegen der Schmerzen.
Sie leidet an Vorerkrankungen an Hyperkolesterinämie seit 10 Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt sie Sinvastatin 20 mg abends ein.
Sie leidet wahrscheinlich an Ulcus ventriculi.
Dagegen nimmt sie Panthoprosol ein.
Bei ihr wurde mit acht Jahren eine Tonsillektomie durchgeführt.
So wie wegen Divertikulose wurde bei ihr eine Hemikollektomie vor acht Jahren durchgeführt.
Divertikulitis ist ein akuter Fall.
Sie leidet an Divertikulose.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich auch.
Sie ist Ex-Trauerin.
Vorher habe sie 20 Jahre lang ein Schachtel Zigaretten geraucht.
Sie trinke ein bis zwei Flaschen Bier wochenlich.
Rogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie ist verwitmet.
Sie hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
In der Familienanamnese fand sich der Vater wahrscheinlich wegen einer Coronärherzkrankheit verstorben.
Die Mutter ist vor 30 Jahren an Bronchialkasinum verstorben.
Die Schwester leidet an Ovarian Tumor.
Der Bruder leidet an Colonkarsinum.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
Vorher habe sie regelmäßig Sport gemacht.
Weiße Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose lautet auf Gonertros.
Dafür schiebt die Lokalisation der Schmerzen und Überwärmung.
Die Differenzialdiagnose ist ein Lumbarbandscheibenvorfall.
Lomatoide Arthritis, Kichtanfall.
In der Diagnose würde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung bei der Patientin durchführen.
Im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich zunächst die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Anschließend würde ich den Patienten eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Dabei würde ich Motorik, Sensibilität, Reflex sowie Gelenkseinschränkung überprüfen.
Zu weiteren Abklärungen würde ich eine Labo-Untersuchung durchführen.
Die Analyse des Blutbildes, der Entzündungswerte und der Dormatoidfaktor.
Im nächsten Schritt würde ich eine operative Diagnose vornehmen.
Ich würde die Medikamentöse Behandlung nicht steroidaler Antirheumatik verschreiben.
Ich würde eine chirurgische Konzilveranlassung verabreichen, um eine Knie-Tipp- oder Intraartikulare Injektion durchzuführen.
Können Sie bitte die Knie-Zonographie aufklären?
Knie-Zonographie, eine operative, begebende Methode.
Wir können die Waschgewebe-Teile und die Knochen mit Hilfe von Schallwellen beurteilen.
Wir tragen ein Gel auf die Haut.
Danach nutzen wir Schallkopf.
Das Gerät hat einen Schallkopf und einen Monitor.
Schallkopf sendet Schallwelle und aufnimmt die Gewebeantwort.
Danach können wir den Monitor beurteilen.
Das ist eine Schmessfrei-Beurteilung.
Es enthält keine Strahlung.
Bei der Schreingerschaft können wir sicherlich nutzen.
Nach der Untersuchung können Patienten wie im Alltag leben.
Wie lange dauert diese Untersuchung?
Diese Untersuchung dauert in der Regel 5-10 Minuten.
Benötigt die Patientin eine spezielle Vorbereitung?
Die Patientin benötigt keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Wie würden Sie diese Patienten behandeln? Stationär?
Nach den Ergebnissen können wir entscheiden.
Wenn die Entzündungswerte nicht erhöht sind, können wir ambulant behandeln.
Was empfehlen Sie dieser Patienten nach der Behandlung?
Nach der Behandlung empfehle ich die Patienten Ernährungsberatung, Gewichtsrediktion, regelmäßige Bewegung und Krankengymnastik.
Können Sie bitte Arthroskopie aufklären?
Arthroskopie ist eine diagnostische Methode, mit der wir das Gelenk beurteilen können.
Zuerst sollten wir einen Schnitt machen.
Dann können wir die Metallinstrumenten durch den Schnitt einführen.
Das Gewebe können wir beurteilen.
Es ist eine schmerzhafte Untersuchung.
Deshalb geben wir örtliche Betäubung oder ganz narkose Patienten vor der Untersuchung.
Nach der Untersuchung braucht die Patientin oder der Patient eine Begleitung.
Sie haben gesagt, dass als die Phrasie diagnostisch Gicht kommen.
Welche Unterschiede gibt es zwischen Gicht und Konorthose?
Der Gichtanfall ist in der Regel plötzlich aufgetreten.
Wir erwarten Ödema mehr als Konorthose.
Die Lokalisation ist auch ein unterschiedlicher Faktor.
Wir erwarten im großen Gichtanfall.
Wir können bei der Laboruntersuchung unterschieden, um eine Harnsäure zu bestimmen.
Okay, gut.
Wir haben noch eine Minute, aber das ist genug.
Haben Sie Röntgenaufnahme gesagt?
Bevor Röntgen aufgenommen wurde, haben Sie CT aufgenommen.
Hab ich falsch verstanden?
Ja, Sie haben Recht.
CT und Ödema.
Warum CT? Im Konorthose?
Ich habe es vergessen, Herr Oberarzt. Entschuldigung.
Wenn es Trauma gibt, wenn ein Knochenbruch ist, dann können wir CT durchführen.
Wir lernen zu viel bei Ihnen. Danke.
Noch eine Minute. Können Sie bitte Röntgenaufnahme aufklären?
Röntgen ist eine bildgebende diagnostische Methode.
Bei der können wir Gewebe und Organe mit Hilfe von Röntgenstrahlung beurteilen.
Es enthält eine Röntgenstrahlung, aber es ist gering.
Während der Untersuchung sollten Sie zum Beispiel Ketten oder Schmuck ablegen.
Sie sollten vor der Untersuchung nicht vorbereiten.
Nach der Untersuchung können Sie die Alltagung beurteilen.
Nach der Untersuchung kann der Patient die Alltagung wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Wie gewohnt fortsetzen. Danke.
Diese Untersuchung dauert nur wenige Minuten. Es ist schmissfrei.
Gut. Sie haben es gut gemacht. Danke.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Guten Abend Herr Oberast. Wir haben einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen die Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich. Bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Kristina Schumolinski. Sie ist 75 Jahre alt, 72 Kilogramm schwer, 1,85 Kilogramm groß.
Die Patienten stellen sich heute bei uns wegen seitheren beiden Seiten Kniegelenkschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung im Koksefog.
Die Schmerzen sind plötzlich aufgetreten, aber im Verlauf der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Der Patienten ist zufolge die Schmerzen stechend. Desweiteren klagt die Patientin über.
Ich kann nicht hören. Die Internetverbindung ist schlecht oder?
Ja, ich habe sie nicht gehört. Sie ist komplett weg.
Herr Erdem, sind Sie da?
Der Hausarzt hat Ibuprofen, Paracetamol und ein Salbe verschreiben.
Die Einnahmen von diesen Medikationen haben keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Die Schmerzen sind früher bei Belastung, aber seit einem Monat in Ruhe aufgetreten.
Sie hatten früher keine anderen Probleme. Die Fragen nach Parasitänz, Hypostasie, Kräfteslosigkeit wurden verneint.
Die Geschichte von Unfall und Verletzung sind unauffällig.
Die Patienten berichteten über einen Gewichtszunahme von 3 Kilogramm innerhalb von acht Monaten.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig auf Obstipation.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf Obstipation.
An den Vorerkrankungen ist die Hypolypidemie seit zehn Jahren.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Die Schmerzen sind plötzlich aufgetreten.
Die Bilder des Gehäbes werden auf einem Monitor dargestellt.
Die Bilder der Bilder der Bilder der Bilder der Bilder der Bilder durch eine Röhreform.
Kamera. In manchen Fallen wird ein Kontrastmittel verabreicht. Nach der Untersuchung ist die
Schmerz frei und ungefährlich. Nach der Untersuchung sollte der Patient viel trinken, um die Kontrastmittel
schnell auf dem Körper ausscheiden. Vor der Untersuchung sollte der Patient alle Metallgestände und Schmuck
ablegen, um diese Bildqualität beinatmen zu können. In manchen Fallen können stattdessen andere
Körperliche Methoden wie CT oder Sonografie durchführen. Aber es gibt wenige Kontrastmöglichkeiten,
die die Patienten schwanger sind oder eine Kontrastmittelallergie oder Nierenversorgung haben.
Wir müssen prüfen, ob diese Untersuchung möglich ist oder andere Untersuchungen ersetzt werden können.